>> Bret: CELEBRITY CHEF
ANTHONY BOURDAIN WAS FOUND DEAD
THIS MORNING IN A HOTEL ROOM IN
FRANCE.
AUTHORITIES SAY HE TOOK HIS OWN
LIFE.
HE BECOMES THE SECOND CELEBRITY
TO APPARENTLY COMMIT SUICIDE
THIS WEEK.
TONIGHT, CORRESPONDENT
LAURA INGLE SAYS IT BRINGS IN
NEW ATTENTION TO A PROBLEM THAT
EXPERTS SAY IS GETTING MUCH
WORSE.
>> OH, YEAH, LOOK AT THAT
GOODNESS.
>> ANTHONY BOURDAIN, THE
LARGER-THAN-LIFE CELEBRITY CHEF
WITH A BAD BOY PERSONA TRAVELED
THE WORLD, TELLING STORIES
THROUGH CASUAL CONVERSATIONS
OVER FOOD AND DRINKS FOR HIS
EMMY-WINNING SHOW ON CNN, PARTS
UNKNOWN.
HE WAS FOUND DEAD TODAY AT THE
AGE OF 61 AFTER HANGING HIMSELF
IN HIS HOTEL ROOM.
HE WAS FILMING IN NEARBY
STRASBURG, FRANCE, FOR ITS
POPULAR SHOW.
THE NEWS OF HIS DEATH SHOCKED
HIS FAMILY, CALLING HIS FANS,
WHO SAID HE LIVED A LIFE OF
TRAVEL, FOOD AND ADVENTURE.
>> THIS IS WHAT YOU WANT.
THIS IS WHAT YOU NEEDED.
THIS IS THE PATH TO TRUE
HAPPINESS AND WISDOM.
>> AT THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL REPORTS SUICIDE IS THE
TENTH LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
UNITED STATES, AND THAT RATES IN
THE UNITED STATES ARE RISING AT
AN ALARMING RATE.
UP NEARLY 30% BETWEEN 1999 AND
2016.
THE NEWS OF HIS SUICIDE COMES
FRESH ON THE HEELS OF FASHION
DESIGNER KATE SPADE'S DEATH THIS
WEEK.
SHE HANGED HERSELF IN AN
APPARENT SUICIDE IN
NEW YORK CITY TUESDAY.
WHILE CELEBRITY SUICIDES CATCH
OUR ATTENTION, WHEN PEOPLE WHO
SEEMINGLY HAVE IT ALL TAKE THEIR
OWN LIVES.
NEARLY 123 PEOPLE COMMIT SUICIDE
IN THE U.S. EVERY DAY.
MEDICAL EXPERTS SAY THAT ONE
THING DOCTORS CAN DO IS ASK
THEIR PATIENTS FLAT OUT IF THEY
ARE IN TROUBLE.
>> ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
SUICIDE?
WE CAN'T BE AFRAID TO ASK PEOPLE
THAT.
PEOPLE THINK WE CAN'T ASK BUT
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE THEM
THE IDEA.
IF YOU ASK THEM, THEY MAY TELL
YOU.
SPEAK OUT THE CDC ALSO REPORTS
THAT MORE THAN HALF THE PEOPLE
WHO DIED BY SUICIDE HAD NO KNOWN
HEALTH PROBLEMS ADDING THAT
RELATIONSHIPS, SUBSTANCE ABUSE,
HEALTH AND FINANCIAL PROBLEMS AE
AMONG OTHER CONTRIBUTING
CIRCUMSTANCES.
YOU CAN LEARN ABOUT WARNING
SIGNS OF SUICIDE AND HELP THOSE
AT RISK BY CALLING THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE AT